speaking of the people the faces the
voices one of the people you've talked
about you've posted about you've written
about is while Al him being hospitalized
he's a Palestinian journalist and the
bureau chief of Al jazer and Gaza City
what can you tell me about this man if W
wasn't Palestinian he'd be on the cover
of Time Magazine right now he would be
the most celebrated journalist in the
world uh
is from Gaza he has been in Israeli
prisons he has been under Israeli air
strikes he has seen the worst of the
occupation before he's seen the worst of
the
genocide while on TV I mean and this is
this is insane when you think about it
we have over a 100 journalists now right
that's more than any conflict in history
that have been killed and there is
sufficient evidence by International uh
Watchdogs that this is intentional that
journalists have been killed
intentionally but then their families
while it was reporting on TV when an air
strike hits his
wife two kids and a
grandchild he goes to the scene and he
said this you know you never expect as a
journalist to be the subject of the
story suddenly the camera is on him
mourning over his dead wife and kids and
grandkid he's saying he even says it in
Arabic he says they're taking it out on
our children they're taking it out on
our
children uh you know I've heard this
from multiple people that have had
relatives targeted that I wish it was me
instead he gets back on camera the same
day because he feels a responsibility to
continue to cover the lives of the
people of Gazza he understands that his
story as devastating as it is is not
unique in regard to the people of Gazza
that there are many people whose
families have been killed in air strikes
all 2 million people have been
traumatized and some way and so he gets
back on camera tells the story again
and then he is targeted
himself uh his arm struck his cameraman
Sam AB dies in front of him he bleeds
out well watches him bleed out for hours
and while and Aid workers try to reach
them in the building that they were in
uh snipers would shoot all of those that
were rushing to S so he watches his
cameraman and one of his best friends
bleed out to death while goes to the
hospital his arm is wrapped up gets
treatment he's back on camera the next
day a few weeks later uh another child
is killed again with his friend uh in in
a car so this was a targeted air strike
his son is
driving and his son and his best friend
are hit in an air strike why it leads
the funeral prayer is back on camera
again and speaks with such dignity with
such compassion you know one of the
things
that always gets to me as as a
Palestinian right and as a Muslim
too is that we are portrayed to be these
beasts and Savages tell me a man that
would be put through what w was put
through and still stand on that on that
pulpit and in front of the world with
such dignity with such Grace continues
to tell the
story has become a hero to many of us
and he would be a hero in a
world that wasn't anti- Palestinian and
unfortunately has not only lost his
family he's not only lost much of his
own existence but wild is part of the
greater story of eraser so even though
he's telling the story of the people of
Gaz and he is the story of the people of
Gazza most people will never learn
about